there's some grand theft auto [ __ ] going
on right now [ __ ] bro you seen that [ __ ]
where the [ __ ] just walked up in the
restaurant
yeah bro that [ __ ] was goofy to me
me and my wife keep it super low key but
i tell my wife when we go out to eat i'm
like leave your she got a big-ass
wedding ring i'm like leave that [ __ ] at
the crib i don't even want to kill you
though bro you don't want unless you're
going to move around with security and
you don't have to do that
a hundred percent feel me like that
should be ass bro people are targets out
here and especially try me out here a
couple times you feel me like i ain't
gonna lie that [ __ ] don't never work me
i'll be too on point like i'm from the
same [ __ ] y'all trying to do i didn't
get to see you feel me like i don't
you're ready for that kind of [ __ ] yeah
yeah i'll be on it
a lot of people need to understand when
they come to l.a don't think this is a
joke well also it's hollywood yeah but
like yo man leave your [ __ ] jewelry
in the hotel room or just leave it at
home
like there's no reason for you to move
around with a hundred thousand dollars
worth if you're gonna do that [ __ ] bro
be safe be safe get some security yeah
like i ain't gonna sit here and say
security is like the end-all be